Chẳng em hẹp tạv nâm tại khẳng định lập trường không có ra nào được kiểm soát air bình hông ốt, trong bối cảnh
cánh thẳng giống Mỹ về Iran tiếp tục lâu thang quanh truyền hàng air trên lần này.
Cú thay tổ thông nghĩa là trăm đẹp bá bỏ thông tin từ chuyên thống Iran về giúp thảo thật.
Chòa phát Iran và Oman cùng quan lí hoạt động hàng air quay bình hông ốt.
Đông thời gian mạnh này là tuyên đường thủy của tế và Washington chưa xem xét dưới bỏ klet trường phát đam vào tây
bà đá bác, chí bà dơ sau tin bú trên, cú đổi mi trò biết đã bán hạc bú mấy bái khúc mấy lạy của Iran và tập tích một chạm
điều khiến tạy thành phố cản bà đá bác, nơi bị các buộc trình bị được dùng để Iran phòng
thêm 1 bếm một quan trích mi một tả đoay là hành động phòng bếng giống vý trí là các bạn mong mong mong mong mong như này.
Đáp lại, bệnh bình kích mong hồi giáo Iran 入 ở gần xe từ mố, đã tấn công một cách khúc hông còn mi để chả đuó
hông kích gần xe bà đá bác và kính báo sẽ phản lúc mấy hơn, được các khu tấn công phim diễn, tuy nhiên
tây ra không đều dõi ạc cạnh tử Mỹ bị nhà mục tiêu năm ở đâu, cuóa t là cuóa ra vuy nhất của cạnh tử Mỹ cho biết đã khiến
hạc hệ thống không thủ, trước các mùi đezuá mong tế lừa vào uống ở bây.